تنضم فرنسي الى دول التي فرضت فحصا سلبيا
على المسافرين من الصين في وقت تشهد فيه
بكين ارتفاعا قياسيا لعدد المصابين بفيروس
كورونا
اسبانيا حدث حدو ايطاليا وفرضت هي الاخرى
قيودا صحيه على المسافرين من الصين محاضره
باحتمال ظهور متحورات جديده خارج عن
السيطره في الصين
لطلب الشهاده الرقميه او ما يعادلها
للوافدين من الصين كما انها تتخذ
الاجراءات اللازمه بالتنسيق مع شركه
العامه اسبانيا تدير المطارات لاجراء
الفحوصات للركاب القادمين من الصين
المانيا
الجديده المحتمله 19 في المطارات
الاوروبيه رفضه فرده فحوصات على الوافدين
من الصين
هذا هو الزمت كل من الولايات المتحده
وكوريا الجنوبيه والهند واليابان وتايوان
المسافرين الوافدين من الصين بالخضوع
لفحوصات كرونه
للمسافرين قبل ركوب الطائره